las operaciones de búsqueda y rescate
están en marcha en el centro de
filipinas esto ha sido posible gracias a
la llegada de equipos pesados y que el
clima se ha despejado seis pueblos de la
ciudad de bay bay se vieron afectados
por desprendimientos de tierra durante
el fin de semana mientras que los
equipos de rescate han empezado a
levantar los cuerpos de las víctimas
mortales
[Música]
solo espero que venga a nosotros aunque
sea en nuestros sueños le echo mucho de
menos
esto fue el momento en el que el nuevo
deslizamiento de tierra golpeó la
provincia de leyte el martes la tormenta
tropical médica había azotado la zona un
día antes que había provocado
inundaciones y corrimientos de tierra
generalizados los médicos se han
apresurado en atender a los
sobrevivientes al tiempo que las
autoridades locales verifican quiénes
siguen desaparecidos se trata de la
primera tormenta tropical que azota a
filipinas en lo que va del año este país
propenso a las catástrofes suele tener
una media de 20 tormentas al año durante
la estación de los monzones que comienzo
en junio pero con el cambio climático
esta nación ha visto como las tormentas
empiezan antes durante el año y según
los científicos su intensidad ha
aumentado
[Aplausos]